changed my life allen's farewell season
starts september 13th it's the end
of an era you know it's the greatest
thing after two decades of television
ellen degeneres will return for the
farewell season of the ellen degeneres
show
starting monday september 13th and in a
new promotional trailer for the upcoming
season
the 63 year old tv personality brings
all
the feels two decades of television
[Music]
we want to give each one of you a
thousand
and one thankful host
i'm not crying you're crying today i am
announcing that next season season 19
is going to be my last season back in
may ellen announced that the show's 19th
season would be its last after former
employees of the daytime talk show
called it out
in a buzzfeed news expose for allegedly
having a quote
toxic work environment which prompted
production to go on hiatus and the show
to launch an
internal investigation a source at the
time told
et that while the allegations made
against ellen were tough
she continued with the talk show because
she wanted to honor her commitment
and her staff through the end of her
contract
and during a sit down with the today
show in may ellen said those allegations
were not the reason for her ending her
show
if it was why i was quitting i would
have not come back this year
i really did think about not coming back
because it did
um you know i mean it was devastating
i am a kind person i am a
person who likes to make people happy
ellen doubled down
saying she's still proud of everything
she and her team achieved with the show
i'm proud of the kind of show we do i'm
proud that we are funny
i'm proud that we are helpful to people
and that we represent
acts of kindness i happen to know that
that washer and dryer is too big for
your apartment
we checked the square footage so we
bought you a house
and highlighting people that we want to
say look at this person doing good
ellen also addressed the news on her
daytime talk show
the truth is i always trust my instincts
my instinct told me it's time as a
comedian i have always understood the
importance of
timing and in all seriousness i
truly have felt like next season was the
right time to end this amazing chapter
and back in 2019 ellen told e.t
she would know when it was time to move
on how are you going to know when it's
the right time to walk away from daytime
um well i hope i know when when people
kind of are tired of me
i think i'll sense that i'll walk away
really when i when i stop having fun
you